have you done something dumb with money
and it's discouraged you that's all of
us babydoll that's all of us
you could have a PhD in mathematics and
be a financial ignoramus it's all of us
you can have a master's degree in
finance and be broke because of your
behaviors your choices your immaturity
your impulsiveness it's all of us we all
have faced those exact same demons no
one is born with a money gene that you
didn't get Dave Ramsey was not born good
with money they didn't walk into the
nursery and go oh that one's gonna
handle money well now I went bankrupt
after becoming a millionaire in my 20s
starting from nothing again because I'm
so stupid I had to do it twice rebuilt
our wealth but you learn the trick is
okay so you leased a car that was stupid
look at the math and understand why it's
stupid it's the most expensive way to
operate a vehicle get out of that deal
either by riding it out or dumping it
selling it and paying the difference
whatever whichever makes the most
financial sense get out of that deal and
never do that again
you know who leases cars broke people
that's who leases cars so you bought a
whole life insurance policy so did I
once
fraternity boy from college that knew my
wife comes by from Northwestern Mutual
and sells us a bunch of crap and I've
got a finance degree and I bought it
then when I started unpacking and
learning how horrible it was
what a trashy pitiful product of
Northwestern Mutual whole life pause it
is I've never made that mistake again I
cancelled that policy I'm only carried
term insurance since then I found our
credit cards are not a source of wealth
building well they have I get points
said broke people everywhere Dave I get
points said no rich person ever rich
people don't know I've never met with a
millionaire or a billionaire and I sat
down with them and said tell me your
financial secrets tell me what the deal
is what I'm doing when I'm asking
millionaires on The Millionaire the
everyday Millionaire theme hour and I
say do you know what advice do you have
for 25 year olds they never say never in
30 years of talking to wealthy people
I've never heard one say you know those
airline miles
that was my financial breakthrough those
discovery points that cash back baby I
changed my life something through the
math okay you get one percent cash back
right that means if you spend a hundred
thousand dollars on that credit card you
get $1,000 back you want tell me how
that is a method to wealth building
that's stupid
it's stupid and broke people say stupid
things about money and they keep doing
the same mistakes over and over and over
again and then they blame the systemic
problems with the economy the little man
can't get ahead no it's your stupid
habits my stupid habits the problem with
my money is the guy I shave with if I
can get that guy to behave he can be
skinny and rich but he's got issues I
like chocolate chip cookies makes it
hard to lose weight makes it hard to
stay in shape right I mean yeah we're
all this way I'm the same way
Dave Ramsey just shames people and
judges people no Dave Ramsey shames and
judges stupid behaviors in himself and
in you I'm not going to endorse your
stupid behavior so that you feel good
about yourself because you're not gonna
end up feeling good about yourself
because you're gonna be broke
we're not shaming any buyer judging
anybody we're streaming behaviors that
don't work
judging behaviors that don't work and if
you can't do that then you can't be a
grown-up that's all about being an adult
right there where they call adulting if
you want to be a Doulton you actually
have to look at stupid stuff and say
that's stupid stuff and not get your
precious little feelings hurt you sweet
little petite flower oh my gosh you know
grow a spine here and face the music and
say you know what that didn't work I
failed I'm not doing that again
make a decision you get to choose and if
you choose to do the same thing over and
over again and you expect the different
results I've been using my credit cards
getting points for years and so you know
it's a dr. Phil moment stupid how's that
working for you you'll show me well I
went to Europe once yeah well what's
your net worth $4 because you keep
spending everything you make because I'm
going to Europe on free airline miles
you're an idiot that's just straight-up
stupid I'm gonna lease my car get a
whole life policy use my credit cards
get a student loan to send my kid to
college and sign up for it as a Parent
PLUS loan and then wonder why I'm broke
and lower middle class cuz you're making
stupid broke middle-class decisions is
why you'll make lower-class decisions I
can help you with lower class decisions
to buy lots of lotto tickets pawn
everything and do rent to own that's
where it's you're finding the poor end
of town isn't it
that's what poor people do and all of
those things feed on poor toast the note
Lots yeah on your car all those things
feed on poor people they don't feed on
the middle class the middle class gets
fed on by other stuff but you can make a
decision to not be poor people anymore
it's hard
I've been bro coming so broke up that
they took the water meter out of the
front of my house they didn't just
disconnect it they took the whole
dad-blame thing and hold it off cuz
that's how bad we were behind with the
water company I've been there I know
what that looks like that is not a good
day because of my stupid choices like
we're making stupid choices I magically
ended up with more money it was magic oh
look at that and then people say you're
so lucky luck had nothing to do with it
dummy not making stupid choices anymore
that's what changed everything start
making wise choices stupid choices The
Fool is juxtaposition with the wise all
through proverbs you can find it there
every day when you read them there's one
a day by the way for 31 days good news
about all this is you can do this
I don't know how scared you are or how
beat up you are but I've been right
where you are you can turn this around
and we're here to help you and we have
been for a very long time and we will be
for a very long time